so here's the panel you have a lot from
dr. Cohen Dean Damon so probably i'm
gonna start was the question for you dr.
Feldman i saw this in this Nikkei or NHK
actually that the Prime Minister decided
to join TPP negotiation it just a start
decide to negotiate first and then
negotiate the terms and conditions with
TPP I don't know your supportable or
you're against it but would you just
comment about the its decision in
pompous Albert as well as the impact you
can see for Japan Japanese are calling
thank you very much for you my son for
that very nice introduction let me just
quickly comment on why I think the TPP
is important but also linked this to the
to the context of the remarks by dr.
Cohen in particular what are the
problems at the world faces and what are
the problems that say CMU or Todai or
other universities need to address to
save the world there are some very very
serious problems out there dr. Cohen
mentioned the energy problem that's at
the top of my list not the physical
problem the energy problem TPP is
important in all of these problems
addressing all of these problems because
it is a comprehensive agreement among
countries to raise interaction at all
levels in many areas there was just a
recent book by a an economist
sociologist physicist etc he does
everything w brian arthur from the Santa
Fe Institute the book i think is called
the nature of technology what is it and
where does it come from and in that book
Arthur said that innovation comes from
the mixture of new ideas aimed toward an
intentional purpose well if you don't
have people getting together in a much
more so dense fashion without that
interaction the new ideas don't come out
so for me TPP is very important because
it will help spur this interaction of
ideas interaction of people at all
levels of society and help us address
some of these issues in food in water in
fiscal deficits and demographics and
entitlements in governance and voting
systems in ethics all of these things
have to work together if we are going to
address the problems that the world
faces right now so from my point of view
yes TPB is very important for Japanese
agriculture to get it up to speed yes
it's very important for opening markets
but it's even more important for
creating the intellectual millio the
intellectual environment in which people
from all countries can get together and
get to work on these issues so that's
why I think it's important now just a
moment question dr. Feldman about the
President Obama now it's in the USA side
US politicians sort of blaming mr.
Obama's gone Pacific for nine days they
saying that a lot of things to do in the
United States to create jobs for
Americans but mr. Obama says always that
the agent Pacific is a big tie with the
creating American jobs how would you
relate those two things together if you
look at the history of trade agreements
among countries starting with the oil
excuse me the coal and steel packed in
Europe just after World War two what
we've seen is the trade agreements among
countries typically increase employment
so not to join a trade agreement to stay
home to look at your belly button well
other people are negotiating trade
agreements is a good way to reduce
employment at
so I think in this case President Obama
is perfectly right the future of demand
growth right now in the world is in Asia
the future of capital accumulation is in
Asia that's how the world makes itself
more prosperous more wealthy the future
of a lot of the progress that we can
make in American society or in Japanese
society as industrial countries is
deeply deeply connected to trade with
Asia after all there are a lot of people
in China and India and other countries
who are still trying to raise their
standard of living how can they do that
without capital accumulation how can
they do that without better technology
those are the things that schools like a
CMU like todai are very good at
producing because we're so international
so to me the notion that you can create
more jobs by staying at home is
ridiculous okay thank you now I had a
plan to have at least three series of
questions for the panel but as I look at
the watch right now I think we have a 15
minutes to go and if we if I don't
involve you into this panel I think
you'll be very bored so now by now you
get some perspective from dr. Cohen
being Damon and dr. Feldman from a
business game point I just want to open
up the panel to you about anything you
want to ask any one of those panels by
that way I just what the want to be a
little more interactor was the the
audience here so i'll point you if you
have any questions or a pointer to
automate those on those point that they
talked about he go Hassan okay well I'm
soon as some questions so long since I'm
working for a major city gas company in
Japan the biggest city gas company and
we advocate of clean energy I want to
add some question related to this and
some people actually I had some meeting
I I listen to the presentation from
Bloomberg guy who mentioned about how
clean energy market goes up and he said
now markets very small butts going up
quickly and I challenge to him that ok
suppose you are walking for GM and
selling car and i purchased it it was
taking 30 minutes to get the supermarket
now is take on only two minutes well i'm
happy so everybody started buying cars
then production goes up and number of
and our price goes down but in case for
clean energy no matter how you make
electricity for the bar take windmills
whatever it is electricity is
electricity you can get any additional
benefit how can we I don't know make it
big business only way we can make this
business in Japan is getting money from
government no way you can make this as
real business and that's a question we
have right now if you have some idea on
this how to be appreciated I'm sure dr.
Feldman has something to say about that
but I will give you my answer it's very
simple a carbon tax if there was a
carbon tax you would need nothing else
to incentivize and see a very rapid
growth in clean energy technologies and
one of the things that drives me
somewhat crazy from the American
perspective is if you get a CEO of an
energy company or any major company
alone in a room and say really what do
you think about cool climate change and
energy you see we should have a carbon
tax but of course publicly that's like
political death you can't even talk
about that in America
but nao that's politics the answer is a
carbon tax or cap and trade or some
variation of it there's such a strong
case for this from it from an economic
perspective from an engineering
perspective that it will happen it's
only a question of when and whether will
happen soon enough I'll just know
Australia just adopted if I may let me
add a couple things I think dr. Cohen
has just pointed out one of the absolute
crucial elements of this which is the
entire world has been mispricing energy
for years and I don't mean two or three
years I mean for the 50 years we have
the wrong price part of it is that we
don't put a price on carbon emissions
another part of it is we don't
apparently far as I can read we do not
put a price on decommissioning nuclear
power plants we don't put a price on a
number of the externalities that are
well-known in the energy business as an
economist in my view is you internalize
the externalities by changing the
pricing structure okay just after the
earthquake here in Japan and the tsunami
the great tragedy some friends of mine
and I were out talking about policy
proposals one of the proposals we made
was to actually raise the price of
energy quite substantially Japanese
energy prices are already high but at
the same time lower income tax and
corporation tax so the net tax take
would be the same but the incentives
from the system would create the most
energy efficient country on Earth by a
long shot japan is already good in fact
it probably is the most energy efficient
of the industrial countries maybe some
of the skin bees do a little better but
we could do much much more so first get
the pricing right second vested
interests japan the united states are
replete with vested interests that are
stopping progress
on the energy agenda in Japan we have
the issue of very heavy involvement of
some of the energy suppliers in
political contributions and this excuse
the development of Technology in one
direction the last 40 years it's been in
favor of nuclear if renewables were
given the same per kilowatt subsidy as
some other energy weren't particular or
or nukes we would probably be farther
along why doesn't it happen because the
system is vulnerable the political
system is vulnerable to vested interests
a third one and this is our job as
eggheads is to be ready with new ideas
good ideas developed ideas when society
is ready to hear them what I mean by
this is as follows I have a model for
thinking about how societies make
decisions or difficult decisions that I
call the creek cycle creek stands for
crisis response improvement complacency
okay this is a sort of a cycle of the
way in political economy very much based
on the old agricultural models such as
the the cobweb model or the hog cycle
okay in the hog business it's easy to
understand takes about two years to
raise a hog okay if prices are high this
year everybody raises hogs two years
from now there are a lot of hogs so the
price goes down nobody raises hogs two
years later there are no Hawks so the
price goes up so you get these big
cycles the same thing happens in many
areas of economic policy without a real
crisis people just don't focus ok this
is inevitable we're all primates we have
a serious myopia our job as eggheads as
thinkers about policy as technologists
in material science in business is to
come up with ideas that are shovel ready
when the price goes up enough to make
people
why did japan shift in favor of TPP a
couple years ago the public mind
basically shifted in favor of
agricultural reform why did that happen
it's because the Russians put on export
controls on grain Japan imports more
grain than any other country on Earth
and people got scared okay what do we do
we have to redo our agricultural system
well in energy it's the same issue
prices will go up again and when they do
we need to be ready with ideas about the
tax system with the political system etc
so we can end this myopia and have a
have a better solution let me stop there
I have some numbers to later on but we
can talk about that later thank you hey
go by the way we just made me reach it
so yeah hi my name is just send ingre
i'm class of two thousand six melon
college of science my question is in
relevance to the diversity of the
student body how do you feel about the
current representation you know socially
economically internationally and what
are we doing going forward in trying to
attract you know the basis is to try to
attract the best students possible but
also there are you know certain
international bodies that are
represented more just because a
population demographic in da china japan
is maybe underrepresented perhaps i
don't know but i just would like to hear
your thoughts on on the diversity of the
campus let me talk from the perspective
of the entire university and the
undergraduate student body and Dean
Damon might want to comment from the
perspective of the temper school
especially the master's class without
questioning an undergraduate student
body is also the most diverse right now
than it has ever been
on many many measures but you're quite
right i inferred from what you said and
i think you intended it this way there
are some regions of the world in some
individual countries that are
under-represented japan being one of
them we used to have many more students
from japan than we do now we currently
have about 40 or so 40 or 45 of from
japan in our student body and by that i
mean the entire student body that's dr.
masters and undergraduate that's 40 some
students out of 11,000 that's about half
what it used to be and i believe it's
primarily because the practice of
corporate sponsorship of students to
study in America has been reduced in
Japan and so money is an issue and that
leads me to the other thing I want to
say about this we are a very expensive
university we know that our tuition is
extremely high we also are a university
because of our really small endowment
which is not only true from the tepper
school but for the entire university we
have limited resources for financial aid
we don't give as much financial aid as
some of the other very expensive very
selective universities the result of
that is that we have too many students
attending whose total whose need
financial need is not being met by the
university the result of which is either
they don't finish well thankfully that
doesn't happen so much anymore or they
graduate with a lot of depth we know
this is a deterrent to some groups of
people in the US and absolutely to
students from other countries because we
don't give financial aid international
students so we are not getting we get
very few international students from
families other than upper middle class
or very wealthy
that bothers us it will only change
though when our endowment gets much
bigger and that will that's what this
campaign is all about and what future
fundraiser will be about to yeah if the
business at the business school were
seeing exactly the same trends that G
Regis just mentioned in the 1980s we we
saw a lot of a lot more students from
Japan corporate sponsored students I
think I just looked at the statistics
before I came here in the entering class
this mba class i think we have five or
six from japan out of a class size of
200 that's that's small we're getting
huge demand for the for our mba program
from india now something like forty
percent of our all of our applications
come from India we could we could fill
our entire class with outstanding
students international students with you
know gmats of over 700 but we value
diversity I mean as a business school
because I think it enhances the
education for everybody and it makes the
program more global to bring those
different perspectives I would like to
see it a bit more diverse from the
international the different countries
that that get represented a little bit
more diversity among the international
countries that we attract about thirty
percent of our total student body is
from outside the US and the trend we're
seeing and I don't know whether this is
just a short-term trend because of the
economy are with whether this is a real
shift the demand coming from the US is
declining for mbas the actual number of
applications has declined three years
straight but from international students
it's really taken off especially from
from India
in China made ok this is the last last
question already boy Fuji you're the
boss you as long as you want I have five
minute battle ok the session so maybe
two questions hi dr. Fieldman um my
name's Lydia and I'm a Heinz graduate of
0 10 and I was just wondering you talked
about the opportunity for intervention
which level ready solutions for energy
and I just wondered what after the
tragedy of 311 where are those being
evaluated in a different way and what
might be some of the consequences and
just generally from a CMU perspective
was there any attention or brainstorming
or different thinking on campus when
that when that event occurred from the
students and just kind of the outreach
that that happened thank you I i would
say that we just continue to do what we
were doing which is to be very actively
exploring and questioning every aspect
of energy production in in in use and
this is true for all forms so nuclear
natural gas is a big local issue now for
those who have not been around that part
our part of the u.s. in the last two
years there's a a deposit of natural gas
held in tight shale formations deep
underground for us it's called marcellus
shale and there's a new way to exploit
this and it has environmental impacts so
we're sort of seeing a reliving of the
coal and gas age in western Pennsylvania
we're very involved Hines students are
doing a project on the water impacts
marcellus shale this semester and their
fact that you're doing research with
regard to nuclear though I can't point
to any particular activity that was
prompted by the event sir this is not a
area of great to expertise on my part
but I do know that in Japan there is
obviously a rethinking of all of the
stages of the energy issue a
conservation was the one that I think
made the most progress in light of what
happened in Fukushima all of a sudden
over the summer the government called on
businesses to cut fifteen percent they
did it if somebody told you tomorrow you
have to got fifteen percent out of your
budget you'd say that's crazy I can't
possibly do it they did it because it
was necessary so when confronted with a
crisis human beings can be very
inventive and so I think on the
conservation side a lot was done and
then things start occurring to people i
had to client meetings today in our
little meeting rooms on the 11th floor
of our building i took both clients to
the window and I tapped on the window is
there anything funny about this window
looked at it they look out the window at
the mikoshi across the street no I don't
see no that's not what it's about it's
about the window it's single paint the
diffusion rate of double paned windows
in japan is very low this is bizarre for
a country that's supposed to be so good
about energy conservation okay so that
is getting me improving I think the
natural gas issue is going very well
here if you look at natural gas prices
in Asia as opposed to the United States
there at royal party in the United
States gasps I understand now is being
priced at the equivalent of 23 dollars a
barrel for oil so a quarter of what is
selling for is in energy terms is what
the gas is selling for in Asia I my
colleague tells me a gas is actually
priced a little bit above parity for oil
which it says to me that there is not
really a good global market in gas it's
harder to move over
than oil okay so what this is asking us
to do is develop new technology to move
gasps around a little more efficiently
so we can start a market in it so all
these things are beginning to happen I
was in Malaysia a couple weeks ago
peninsular malaysia not the borneo part
Peninsular Malaysia is going to start
being a net importer of gas in the next
few years this is very different world
they're going to have to build import
facilities so there's a huge recognition
around the world that gas is our future
for the next few years but we after that
we're not really sure about the
technology I hope it's accelerating in
all areas even in nooks I'm not
theoretically against nukes I just want
to see the technology to make them
really cheap ok and a little safer get
the waste issues so but we need call it
a reallocation of budget toward the
technology side in order to get this
done and that runs up against a wall
when you've got a government here a
government in the United States the
governments in Europe that are unable to
control entitlement spending so this is
the issue that we're facing and I hope
in the next budget our government here
in Japan comes up with that we at least
make some steps toward taking money out
of the budget for shall we say spending
in social areas that is really not very
productive like torturing old people in
hospitals we do a lot of that okay and
we shouldn't do that because our our
ethics haven't caught up with our
technology yet my favorite quotations
from a Martin Luther King she's talking
about how our ethics haven't caught up
with our science and he says we have
guided missiles but misguided men it's a
very nice quote that's exactly what
we've got if we're going to solve these
energy problems we have to make
decisions like that so if you're over 50
look in the mirror and say the problem
is me because we're the ones who have to
say okay we have to give up something
out of our you know expected benefits to
make the world a better place and I hope
that realization is spreading who just
want a number to read of course first
point dr. Feldman made with regard to
conservation in the
u.s. energy economy fifty-five percent
of all the energy that's either
extracted or produce store transmitted
is lost it is never used it's lost along
the way fifty-five percent so that you
know the opportunities there for gains
for finding new energy are phenomenal
but we need to have incentives enter
price is right let me add one more
number I did some very simple
calculations you'll probably laugh at
this but I started with global energy
you primary energy use in 2007 the
number i got was 96.7 you know
quadrillion zillion whatever units it
was okay they start at 96.7 if we repeat
the miracle with the last 20 years that
is three and a half GDP growth three and
a half percent gdp growth but only two
percent primary energy growth if we
repeat that miracle for the next 50
years 2% primary energy growth and then
add it all up okay take that next fifty
years worth of energy use that comes to
about eight point four trillion barrels
of oil equivalent 8.4 how much do we
have in fossils today well current
proven reserves of oil regular natural
gas and coal are about 5.7 if you add in
the extra shale gas that dr. Cohen just
mentioned the US government estimate 1.1
trillion barrels of oil equivalent so
you get 6.8 we need 8.4 we've got 6.8 so
there's a gap already and by the way
after 50 years the 6.8 the fossil stuff
is gone we've got to grow the
alternatives or shall we say the the
combination of renewables and
conservation at the pace of about five
point eight percent per year every year
for the next 50 years to make sure that
the lights are still on when the fossils
are gone that's the issue we're facing
when I did those numbers just a couple
weeks ago I was scared I was genuinely
scared am i off base on
overthrow okay another number here okay
the particular the statics as well that
there are three segments of energy
consumption transportation like jet
engines and watching concern the other
ones as factories when you look at the
energy consumption increase rate from
1990 for 20 years to today
transportation segments and a factories
did increase much at all yeah flat what
was increasing at thirty percent is
residential side and and commercial
buildings or so from 1990 to today
residential and commercial buildings
spent thirty five thirty five percent
every year to till today so we as a
company lixil we are campaign zero
energy home or zero energy building
which we can do with the technology we
have a little bit and you'll be happy to
sell on the separately but that would
say 20 nuclear plants yes that's
something we can do not only by the
effort these talk about but also the
technology that we developed together
dr. Cohen measured about 50 pipes and
lost till when we get to the home or in
the buildings in Japan issues the last
of all my of the total smart grid so if
we solve this the last one mile of the
grid by reducing the consumption or am
that would be a totally different world
that good it just imagine if there is a
carbon tax or some right pricing these
things would take off people clamor for
absolutely surfing whatever yeah so I
think of this I'm not these guys know a
lot more about energy and alternative
energies than I do so I think of these
things as an akan
and the carbon tax is is good for many
reasons but I think perhaps one of the
most important ones is that I personally
don't trust the the the politicians to
be able to figure out what the right
alternative is so having government
invest in alternatives and make
decisions they're not very good at
choosing winners and losers in fact
they're pretty the track record is not
good on that and if you've been reading
anything about the u.s. you probably
have read about some of the investments
that the government is made in some
alternative energy companies that didn't
quite make it so to speak so the
advantage of a carbon tax is clearly
then you put the onus on the private
sector to figure out what the best
alternatives are and I have much more
confidence in the free market being able
to do that and so I think that for me is
the real reason why a carbon tax is the
way to go you get the right question to
spend 15 minutes on this subject